they say
Michael Jackson is my hero he is the
reason I am Who I am today
ABC is bringing the nostalgia back to
prime time with their new show greatest
hits a six week music event featuring
the biggest hit makers of the past three
decades and some never-before-seen duets
this week's episode is all about the
early 80s the hosts are an unlikely duo
Arsenio Hall and country star Kelsea
Ballerini we're a good pairing where
we're not hearing yeah it's kind of
funny because a lot of times when we're
writing intros her line is and that was
before I was born in next week's episode
Meghan Trainor gets to live out a
childhood dream
so this is my first bachelor boy sponsor
and ever and I have the best seat in the
house they're like literally singing the
song to me and I freaking out
this kind of opened up an idea of maybe
doing you know a collaboration because
we've always thought about we've never
done something with a female actually
this is our first performance that we've
ever done with a female know the nicest
guys ever and they're goofballs and they
make me feel really comfortable on stage
and less nervous than I was this morning
I was like I supposed to be in their
band all along I don't know born too
late and when it comes to throwback
music well let's just say the Backstreet
Boys are big fans fridge
humanely the cure
right
I mean there's it's this huge laundry
list I mean the 80s and 90s there's like
I think personally some of the best
music ever ever and then there's a group
it was a group called the Backstreet
Boys